you will emerge today's episode let's
work with others the art of cooperation
as you venture out into this new
American frontier you may find yourself
a little lonely
chin up there sport
your fellow vault 76 dwellers will have
emerged as well brave the new world
together but don't become too attached
too quickly when making new
acquaintances practice the art of
nonverbal communication to gain that
interpersonal edge remember cooperation
is the key to success there's no I in
nuclear wasteland employ these proven
techniques and your camaraderie will
blossom in fact you might just make some
lifelong friends of course not everyone
will be quite so neighborly beware the
clever ploy in the event of catastrophe
search for opportunity should you find
yourself alone once more don't fret
replacing those old friends with new
better friends is a snap see you're
prepared for anything
[Music]
now you know the benefits of working
with others you are completely prepared
for the world above with exciting new
social skills as a hand-picked resident
of vault 76 it is your duty to carefully
review your vault-tec provided films
yearly to fully prepare for the day when
you will emerge
play the beta first on Xbox one
[Music]